britain's prime minister calls the
suicide bombing an ariana grande concert
in manchester england
a callous terrorist attack and police
believe
they know who did it you can hear the
bomb go off and see the panic unfold
in video taken from inside the
manchester arena
oh my god
what's going on
oh my god
the explosion happened as people were
leaving the concert
thousands of young people scrambled to
get away from the scene
officials say 22 people died in
britain's worst terrorist attack
since the 2005 transit attacks in london
59 others were wounded police say the
lone bomber was
also killed in the attack president
trump reacted this morning after meeting
the palestinian authority president in
the west
bank so many young beautiful innocent
people
living and enjoying their lives
murdered by evil losers
in life i won't call them monsters
because they would like that term
they would think that's a great name
i will call them from now on
losers because that's what they are
they're losers
and we'll have more of them but they're
losers
just remember that mark phillips is in
manchester with the very latest on this
investigation and reaction to the attack
mark good morning
good morning and a shocking and tragic
one here and a very quick moving
investigation police here say they not
only know the name of the attacker
they've now made another arrest
a 23 year old man in the greater
manchester area
this attack was notable not just for the
number of victims
that it claimed but also for their age
this was a concert for young people kids
many of whom will now not grow old
[Music]
the concert was a sellout and was just
ending
the last song sung the young happy crowd
was beginning to file
out of the arena
oh my god a dash cam in the parking lot
caught the blast
[Applause]
the crowd began to panic the bomber was
not in the arena
he had come to the concert on the local
rail system and had approached one of
the main exits as the audience was
making its way out
some meeting parents well the lights
came up after the concert and everyone
was getting up to leave
and all of a sudden there was a big fan
and all of the seats
like shook and everyone just started
running people were screaming and crying
this has been the most horrific incident
we have ever faced here in greater
manchester
manchester police chief ian hopkins says
there are many young people among the
victims
we believe the attacker was carrying an
improvised explosive device
which he detonated causing this atrocity
the bomb was designed to kill and maim
many of the survivors suffered shrapnel
wounds
there had been security at the concert
but the bomber did not apparently
attempt to get in
his victims came to him it'd been a good
evening until then
this morning concert goers were
wandering the streets of manchester
many still unable to make sense of what
had happened
you wouldn't think something that would
happen to you yeah and then when it
happens to you it's just so
like unreal you don't how do you how do
you feel this morning is it really going
to happen it really hits you britain's
prime minister theresa may expressed her
country's horror
and resolve all acts of terrorism
are cowardly attacks on innocent people
but this attack stands out for its
appalling
sickening cowardice deliberately
targeting
innocent defenseless children and young
people
who should have been enjoying one of the
most memorable nights of their lives
police now say that the attacker here
who they say acted alone had
identification on him and they since of
course confirmed
his id the second arrest here seems to
be part of a
massive counter-terrorism operation
that's underway trying to determine if
although the
bomber acted alone here he had a backup
network that helped him plan this
carnage
or that knew of it nora that search will
continue mark phillips in manchester
thank you very much